i'm streaming from my laptop i
not using a mouse i'm using a touchpad
which maybe isn't the most ideal because
i will be playing
bullets against takaru
oh is carl playing already show the
shirt oh yeah i have merch
people can use a merch command i forgot
to disable the coupon code
so the launch the launch coupon code
still works
um i'm going to try not to blunder any
queens today
at least willingly why is zocaro playing
low-rated players because he's trying to
break a world record
but somehow they let me they're letting
me play this event
because i i guess i'm low-rated enough
try to to fit into the competition
there's a funny line jocaro mentions in
his bullet book
you can do it for white or black this
this this this
this this and then like he'll pre-move
this and then i win the rook
um but do i stoop that low
i don't know i feel like i kind of have
to that's my only chance right
i could bond clown
try to get a game where like i bong
cloud
roy lopez on passant
for the memes hey it's lafong oh lafong
i mentioned your name
a few minutes ago if lafong is here
i kind of feel inspired i want a la fong
hakaru
like d4 because you can play d4 bishop
like he's playing g6 bishop g7 every
game
so i could play d4 bishop h6
but i'm gonna be i'm probably gonna be
black
oh no my world record
yeah i'm hoping that's what hikara will
say after i play him
wait i have to be ready okay
yeah i'm not ready ah
my time start ah it does i'm so slow
oh we're playing a line that chabal
played against me
a while ago okay we're playing normal
chess
i think the rook belongs here
um that's a good move have to take
don't hurt me
don't hurt me ah he's hurting me uh
play this move
no
okay you can still catch them maybe
i have a knight knights can be tricky
never resign when you have wait where's
my time
okay never resign when you have a knight
okay i have to uh still may trap him
ah
yeah stop it
ah he heard me ah
that's unfortunate
there goes my uh my hopes of ruining
hakara's world record
oh he said i put up a good fight well
those are kind words
yeah he kind of rolled over me i felt
like i was holding on until e6
and then the whole position kind of
crumbles
right i'll just copy the pgn
and then bring it in to leech us
where's my emojis there we go
ah this graph so i was better for a
single
no multiple moments this
this beautiful graph so i was better
on move four what oh because stockfish
doesn't like the grand prix for some
reason
wants me to play b6 but this is very low
depth stockfish
so i played a5 and then
wait can i zoom in like this oh maybe
that's better
okay so for a very brief moment i'm
slightly better if i take the pawn
oh because i get the bishop pair
potentially like takes takes
uh takes and then probably c5
and then this bishop is good but it's
hard to be precise in one minute
and then yeah by the time he
got the pawns rolling this is really
hard to come back from
oh he missed e6 here oh
but it's still really difficult for
black
i have to have to be very accurate
okay well gigi hikaru
it's it is nice to at least be part of
history
right